I'm a former US visa officer
and today I'm here to talk to you about errors on the DS-160
the first thing you need to know
is that the DS-160 is an important document in your application
it needs to be accurate and it needs to be truthful
in order to present it at your recent interview
so if you notice that there are errors on it
or it was submitted before you could thoroughly review it
then this video is for you
first of all
it's understandable if you need to get some help filling out the DS-160
it's a convoluted document
sometimes the system is slow or it shuts you out
and so getting some assistance to fill it out
it's fine however
you want to realize and take
account of the fact that you need to be the expert on your DS-160
so even if you have someone helping you with it
you still need to review it thoroughly
you need to ensure that the information put there is accurate
and you cannot just put the responsibility
of this application on someone else
the visa officer is not going to be impressed
if you come to the visa interview and say
they ask you a question about something on the DS-160 and you say oh
I didn't know that was in there or I didn't know that it was written that way
I didn't fill it out
my attorney did or my agent did
this is gonna be a really fast way to get the officer not to take your
application very seriously
so if you do have an error
and you realize after it's been submitted that you need to update it
I wanted to talk to you about a few suggestions here
first is you wanna
consider if the change that needs to be made is actually material to your case
there are some non material errors
that of course
it would be better if everything were 100% perfect
but they're not likely to impact the outcome of your case for example
if the zip code of your house address is one number off
or the city of birth where you were born has a typo in it
those kind of things are not going to materially
usually impact the outcome of your case
and if you have one or two errors like that in your DS-160
you might not need to update it
now if your entire DS-160 has typos and errors all over it
that's when you might want to consider updating it just for that
but if it's just one or two small things
possibly you could just let it be
now let's talk about
material errors
these are things that could impact the outcome of your case that are information
that needs to be shared with the visa officer
and then if it's not accurate
could negatively impact the impression the visa officer has
and the decision they ultimately
make about your case
some of this stuff includes
for your current job
your education
if you submitted a DS-160
you know a year ago
and now your appointment is finally coming up
and you've gotten a new job
or you finished a new degree
you should probably fill out a new DS-160
so they are looking at an accurate reflection of your most recent situation
not something that reflects your life a year ago
other things that are really important to get right there
include this
the spelling of your name
your date of birth
and your passport number
if any of those are wrong
you should probably update your DS
one sixty also
there are a lot of security questions on the DS-160 like
have you ever been to jail
have you ever been arrested
have you ever violated US immigration law
and you know
at least 50 more questions about security matters
and if you have not answered those accurately
you may have a difficult time getting your visa approved
so you wanna be very truthful there
and make sure that all of the answers to the security
questions are truthful and reflective of your situation
so if you've decided that there is something on your DS-160 that requires correction
that you really need
to submit a new one in order to put your best foot forward
for this visa application
here is what you need to do first
you need to fill out a new
DS-160
you do this by going to the same C act website
and I'm gonna leave some instructions
in the comments below about how to recreate your old DS-160 so that you don't have to type everything in again
this will help save some time
as obviously
filling out the DS-160 takes a while
and it's a little bit burdensome
once you have
verified that all the information is correct
that it looks good
and you submit it
you're gonna get a new
confirmation page
and you're gonna have a new
confirmation number
that confirmation number
you're gonna want to communicate
to the help desk at the consulate where you're applying
now this is kind of the confusing part
once you've got the new DS-160
every consulate
works a little bit differently
and so there are some consulate
few of them but some
where they allow you to change the DS-160 directly in the system
other consulate
will not allow you to change the DS-160
in the system
and this is the majority of them
so what you're gonna have to do is first write to the help desk and ask them
to to update the DS-160 number
it will sometimes do this
but it's not always a guarantee
so what you also wanna
do is bring a copy of your old
DS-160
confirmation page
and your new
DS-160
confirmation page
bring both of those
to your interview
on the day of your interview
when as soon as you walk into the door
and you see support
staff guiding
you through the line
and all of that
tell them that you have a new DS-160
hey I have a new DS-160
can you ensure that it's
uploaded into my case
I'll take a look real quick
and make sure that the right number is in there
and then when you get to the visa
interview window
also give the visa
officer your
new DS-160
confirmation page
they will be able to scan it
and if it isn't loading
into their system
they'll be able to fix it
so that it will load into the system
and they can read that one first
if you have any questions about what you need to be putting in
the DS-160
how you're going to answer
the questions in there
or if you have errors
and you really wanna
figure out whether or not it's material
and you need to fill out a new one
we're happy to help you
hear it Argo Visa
and we look forward to being in touch